keine bunte arena münchen wollte morgen
mit regenbogenfarben ein zeichen für
toleranz und vielfalt senden
doch die uefa sagt nein einigung beim
klimaschutzpaket die koalition will mehr
wind- und solarenergie und weniger
emissionen einem mieter entlastung beim
co2 preis soll es aber nicht geben
gedenken an 27 millionen kriegsopfer vor
genau 80 jahren überfiel hitler
deutschland die sowjetunion
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann und
wir beginnen noch gleich mit dem
sportpolitischen aufreger thema des
tages
da hat die ruhe war wirklich eine welle
der empörung ausgelöst bei sportlern bei
den fans bei politikern und das weiß
gott nicht nur jetzt fakt ist die
münchner allianz-arena darauf morgen
beim spiel deutschland gegen ungarn
nicht in regenbogenfarben leuchten gegen
eva hat eine entsprechende anfrage der
stadt münchen abgelehnt begründung die
europäische fußball union sei eine
politisch neutrale organisation die
aktion des stadtrats sollte ein protest
sein gegen den offenen homophoben kurs
der orban regierung das ungarische
parlament hatte vor wenigen tagen ein
gesetz verabschiedet das unter anderem
verbietet an schulen über homo und
transsexualität aufzuklären
so hätte die arena in münchen morgen
erstrahlen können für respekt für
vielfalt für weltoffenheit wie schon
erstmals vor fünf jahren zum christopher
street day
doch für den wunsch der stadt münchen
gibt es anleihen des aktuellen stadion
mieters der uefa wird das zu bunt
angesichts des politischen kontext ist
eine botschaft die auf eine entscheidung
des ungarischen nationalen parlaments
abzielt muss die uefa diesen antrag
ablehnen auf jeden fall bin ich sehr
enttäuscht und findet tatsächlich das
ist definitiv keinen gefallen getan hat
mit dieser entscheidung
könnte sein denn der protest der
homosexuellen verbänden ungarn hier
bilder aus der vergangenen woche findet
so noch mehr beachtung zum unwillen der
regierung sieht baut auf einflussreiche
verbündete im osten europas nicht um
fußball verband das gesetz schützt
ungarische kinder und dagegen wird jetzt
in westeuropa protestiert und sie wollen
das mit einem sportevent vermischen das
ist sehr schädlich das zeigt auch die
geschichte das weiß man gerade in
deutschland in fernsehspots predigt die
uefa zwar respekt und vielfalt durch die
begeisterung für die regenbogen bewegung
hat grenzen
wir tun uns mit der entscheidung
natürlich schwer zumal eben die
möglichkeit auch gegeben hätte jedem
alternativen zu finden das heißt alle
sich daran mit
können nicht nur diese eine standort
deutschlands fußballer wollen aber
weiter farbe zeigen ja zunächst mann
hätten wir es uns sicherlich auch
gewünscht so ein zeichen aber die uefa
hat jetzt anders entschieden zeichen
sind gut aber wichtig für mich dass man
danach lebt viele wollen jetzt für
münchen ein springen morgen sollen
stadien in köln frankfurt und viele
andere regenbogenfarben leuchten auch
der viel gescholtene dfb ist dafür
wir setzen uns jetzt dafür ein dass
alternative aktionen die zulässig sind
auch gemacht werden und setzte auch
darauf dass man die zuschauer im stadion
ein klares signal geben fußball und
politik noch ein grund mehr morgen nach
münchen zu schauen wer jetzt schon weiß
man nach berlin
das bundesverfassungsgericht hatte die
regierung ende april aufgefordert den
klimaschutz zu verbessern damit nicht
die nachfolgenden generationen alles
ausbaden müssen das könnte jetzt noch
vor der sommerpause klappen
die große koalition hat sich auf neue
energiepolitische maßnahmen geeinigt
übermorgen soll der bundestag darüber
abstimmen matthias feld auf hat die
details einen deutlichen ausbau der
solarenergie plant die bundesregierung
damit das ziel der klimaneutralität
früher erreichbar wird auf dem tag der
industrie aber mahnt bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel dass auch dieses ziel
nicht zum nulltarif zu haben seien
wir werden in den nächsten jahren
gigantische summen ausgeben müssen
das ist einerseits die aufgabe der
wirtschaft aber ich will ganz ehrlich
sagen es gibt viele bereiche in denen
der ohne staatliches geld gar nicht mehr
in die vorankommen werden morgen ist das
neue klima paket im kabinett das
erreichen der klimaneutralität wird auf
2045 vorgezogen windkraft und
photovoltaik sollen massiv aufgestockt
werden windenergie um 25 prozent die
solarenergie um 200% keine einigung gibt
es auf künftige konkrete co2
preissteigerungen die industrie beklagt
die rahmenbedingungen seien immer noch
zu schwammig aber geht es nicht um die
farbe des stroms nicht um die farbe des
wasserstoffs aber es geht um
verlässliche planbare und kalkulierbare
mengen und verfügbarkeiten
die koalition hat mehrere streitpunkte
einfach ausgeklammert der spd war die
teilung der co2 kosten auf öl und gas
zwischen mietern und vermietern wichtig
die union war dagegen jetzt müssen diese
hohen zusätzlichen kosten allein die
mieterinnen und mieter stemmen und so
stellen wir uns sozialen klimaschutz
nicht vor
für die opposition ist der ganze plan
unzureichend bei den maßnahmen gibt es
wieder nicht mehr als ein paar kleine
förderprogramme es fehlt an
grundsätzlichen reformen und so wird
wohl spätestens nach der bundestagswahl
ein weiteres klimapaket folgen theo koll
in berlin wie berechtigt ist die kritik
an dem neuen gesetz tja wie berechtigtes
kritikern gut aber für viele nicht gut
genug dieses klimaschutzgesetz ist vor
allem jahr mehr zukunftsziel als weg
dahin die klimaneutralität soll jetzt
fünf jahre früher erreicht werden als
bisher geplant das entspricht ja auch
dem urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
das vor kurzem vorgegeben hatte das
recht auf zukunft nachfolgender
generationen müsse stärker geschützt
werden das hat die groko nun erstaunlich
schnell umgesetzt und natürlich hat die
regierung dabei auch auf den wahlkampf
geführt denn eine allzu offene klima
flanke die will sich natürlich keine der
beteiligten parteien an tun also das
reiseziel hat die koalition jetzt im
letztmöglichen parlamentarischen moment
festgelegt den genauen weg dahin muss
dann ab herbst die nächste regierung
finden
dankeschön für diese informationen theo
koll aus berlin
finanzielle unterstützung auch für den
klimaschutz kommt von der eu mehr als 25
milliarden euro aus dem corona hilfsflug
ihn an deutschland
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen gab
bei einem treffen mit kanzlerin merkel
grünes licht für die deutschen pläne das
geld ist größtenteils für den
klimaschutz die digitalisierung und das
gesundheitswesen vorgesehen
insgesamt sind in den hilfspaket 750
milliarden euro für alle ebenen
mitglieder vom börsenliebling zum
beispiellosen betrugs unternehmen vor
einem jahr flogen die gefälschten
bilanzen des 2
des dienstleisters wirecard auf der
wirtschaftliche schaden geht in die
milliarden nach vorstand marschalek wird
weiter gefahndet
politisch unter druck
bundesfinanzminister stolz sein
ministerium hätte viel früher reagieren
müssen heißt es von union und opposition
im untersuchungsausschuss
der legt heute seinen abschlussbericht
vor florian mayer als der wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss seinen
abschlussbericht vorlegt hat der
bundestagspräsident doch eine kleine
nachfrage ob die koalition im ausschuss
auch fest zusammen gestanden sei will
wolfgang schäuble wissen die meisten
heute zumindest nicht da erhebt die
union massive vorwürfe gegen
spd-finanzminister olaf scholz wenn ein
bundesfinanzminister an keiner stelle
die die verantwortung seines hauses
betrifft
irgend etwas mitbekommt irgendwelche
gespräche geführt hat sich an nichts
erinnert natürlich trägt er dann die
politische verantwortung jahrelang
fälschte dass wirecard management die
bilanzen ohne das ist der finanzaufsicht
bafin auffiel
die wiederum dem finanzministerium von
scholz untersteht und so stimmt auch die
opposition in die anklage ein rad in
diesen zeiten bräuchte deutschland eine
führungspersönlichkeit die eben auch
fehler einräumen kann und ich glaube das
ist etwas was olaf scholz nicht
gegebenes einen rücktritt fordert heute
nur die afd
vor 25 jahren wäre ein minister an der
stelle denke ich zurückgetreten und das
ist so ein kulturwandel den wir hier in
deutschland erleben termin nicht gefällt
die spd hingegen sieht vor allem die
privaten wirtschaftsprüfer von drei in
der verantwortung die wirecard über
jahre positive zeugnisse ausgestellt
hatten dass auch der koalitionspartner
den spd-minister angreift dafür gebe es
eine einfache erklärung ich halte das
für wahlkampfgetöse der union und die
behauptungen die aufgestellt wurden
haben sich auch während der zahlreichen
sondern dass untersuchungsausschusses
nicht bestätigt in der bewertung teilt
sich der ausschuss heute in zwei lager
in der praxis hat er in kurzer zeit viel
erreicht unter anderem eine
neuaufstellung der finanzaufsicht bafin
zur corona lage in deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 455 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 197 weniger als vor einer woche
77 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu die sieben tage ins ident sinkt
bundesweit auf acht
auch in italien sinken die zahlen jetzt
hat die regierung beschlossen die masken
pflicht ab montag aufzuheben zumindest
im freien in innenräumen und
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln uns
weiterhin maske getragen werden und auch
die abstandsregeln gelten weiter draußen
wie drinnen unternehmen barbarossa unter
diesem decknamen überfiel nazi
deutschland die sowjetunion heute genau
vor 80 jahren mitten in der nacht um 3
uhr 15 beginnt die überraschende
invasion der wehrmacht mehr als 3
millionen soldaten marschieren rein
am ende hat die sowjetunion 27 millionen
tote zu beklagen so viele wie kein
anderes land
henriette domizil am sowjetischen
ehrenmal in berlin kranzniederlegung von
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
ein kranz für 27 millionen opfer tote
aus allen teilen der sowjetunion in
moskau würdigt russlands staatschef
wladimir putin an der kremlmauer die
kriegshelden seines landes ein
gemeinsames gedenken gab es heute nicht
[Musik]
am 22
juni 1941 fällt die deutsche wehrmacht
in die sowjetunion ein
die erinnerung so steinmeier in seiner
zentralen gedenkrede am vergangenen
freitag bleibe uns deutschen eine
verpflichtung und der welt ein mahnmal
es sei die radikalisierung eines krieges
hin zum wahn totale vernichtung gewesen
ein mann aus unserem dorf erzählte uns
dass onkels asyl gefoltert und verbrannt
wurde
sie verbrannten auch die schwester
meiner mutter die ein sechs monate altes
mädchen hatte meine freundin mania tour
hannover wurde verbrannt viele andere
dorfbewohner
dimensionen eines verbrechens so der
titel einer ausstellung in berlin
karlshorst mit dem gedenken an
sowjetische kriegsgefangene wird eine
wichtige lücke geschlossen
das erinnern auch oder gerade 80 jahre
später noch immer schwierig die opfer
und kränkungen osteuropa allgegenwärtig
in deutschland oftmals verdrängt so
experten
da gibt es auch so ein ungleichgewicht
in der dauer der erinnerung in der in
der gegenwärtigkeit der krieg ist in den
osteuropäischen ländern wirklich noch
gegenwärtig bei uns ist er geschichte
doch der krieg so bundespräsident
steinmeier bleibe spürbar wie eine narbe
über die man mit dem finger streicht
nach afghanistan dort läuft seit anfang
mai de truppen abzug der nato und es
passiert genau das was viele befürchtet
hatten die islamistischen taliban sind
wieder auf dem vormarsch im ganzen land
haben sie seit mai mehr als 50 bezirke
erobert weitere gebiete sind umkämpft
die bundeswehr ist noch mit mehr als
1000 soldatinnen und soldaten in
afghanistan
katrin eigendorf berichtet
machtdemonstration so wie hier in gasen
die posieren taliban kämpfer in vielen
afghanischen provinzen
die verhandlungen mit der regierung in
kabul liegen auf eis die aufständischen
sind im krieg selbst in masar i scharif
wo die bundeswehr ihren stützpunkt hat
sind die kämpfer bis an die stadtgrenze
vorgerückt die afghanische armee ist zum
wichtigsten angriffsziel der taliban
geworden seitdem die usa ihren abzug aus
afghanistan verkündet haben jetzt
bereiten sich soldaten überall im land
auf krieg vor in einer nationalen
offensive will die regierung die
aufständischen zurückschlagen
experten hatten die usa wiederholt
gewarnt bei einem abzug der
internationalen truppen in afghanistan
von den taliban überrannt zu werden nun
steht das land am rande eines
bürgerkrieges und die errungenschaften
der letzten 20 jahre drohen in wenigen
monaten verspielt zu werden
vor allem frauen fürchten nun überall im
land ihre rechte zu verlieren
afghanistans erster frei gewählter
präsident hamid karsai erklärte im
interview mit dem zdf er wolle
versöhnung mit den taliban
doch frauenrechte seien nicht
verhandelbar die rechte die währungen
haben die freiheit die wir haben müssen
wir schützen
besonders die bildung unserer mädchen
dieses recht werden wir mit allen
mitteln verteidigen
der kampf ist in mehr als der hälfte des
landes verloren in den provinzen in
denen taliban im schattenriss ihm
etabliert haben rechtsextreme vorfälle
und andere skandale ausgerechnet in der
bundeswehr eliteeinheit ksk seit monaten
wird das kommando spezialkräfte deswegen
durchleuchtet nun so die
verteidigungsministerin habe nach
einigen reformen ein positiver wandel
stattgefunden nur reicht das andreas
huppert mit stimmen aus dem
verteidigungsausschuss des bundestags
vierte ksk sondersitzung des
verteidigungsausschusses wieder muss
annegret kramp karrenbauer den
abgeordneten rede und antwort stehen
erklären wie sie die skandale im
kommando spezialkräfte in den griff
kriegen will
diesmal hat die ministerin an 31 seiten
starkes reformpapier für die elitetruppe
mit im gepäck
man muss sagen es ist eine umfangreiche
aufarbeitung gegeben hat aus unserer
sicht sind die maßnahmen noch nicht
abgeschlossen auch die aufarbeitung noch
nicht und eine neue aufstellung kann ich
so auch noch nicht festhalten
das ksk seit längerem ist die
spezialtruppe in verruf vor allem durch
saufgelage und neonazistische
einstellungen einiger soldaten und auch
bei der handhabe von munition und
sprengstoff nehmen es die elite soldaten
nicht ganz so genau
zehntausende schuss munition und auch
handgranaten kommen abhanden ohne
erlaubnis des verteidigungsministeriums
er lässt ksk kommandeur kreitmeier eine
art amnestie anonym und straffrei kann
munition zurückgegeben werden daraufhin
wird der kommandeur versetzt all die die
mitverantwortung zu tragen haben machen
sich jetzt einen schlanken fuß wir
wollen das ksk es muss weitergehen aber
ich hoffe sehr dass da jetzt besser
hingeschaut wird
geplant ist so steht es im reformpapier
künftig bei der auswahl der
elitesoldaten nicht nur auf physische
fähigkeiten zu achten sondern mehr auch
auf das demokratieverständnis die
dienstaufsicht beim umgang mit munition
soll grundlegend verschärft werden wir
haben ja ein ganzes sammelsurium an
missständen in diesem verband entdeckt
und es sind beileibe noch nicht
aufgeklärt ich gehe davon aus dass uns
das ksk
auch in der kommenden wahlperiode noch
beschäftigen wird fest steht das ksk
bleibt bestehen die pläne ist komplett
aufzulösen sind vorerst vom tisch
nach der ersten sommerhitze gibt es vor
allem im süden und südwesten wieder
heftige unwetter so ging im osten
münchens ein hagelsturm lieder und regen
überschwemmte ganze straßen eine schwere
gewitterfront war in der nacht über die
region holen in baden württemberg
gezogen hier versanken autos in den
fluten
die insassen konnten sich noch
rechtzeitig in sicherheit bringen
wie gut das wollen wir hoffen dass das
wetter morgen in münchen besser ist beim
letzten deutschen vorrundenspiel gegen
ungarn
ein punkt würde dem dfb team schon
reichen für den einzug ins achtelfinale
die mannschaft hochmotiviert und auch
die angeschlagenen handels und gündogan
melden sich wieder einsatzbereit
der äußere eindruck trügt es herrscht
eitel sonnenschein bei der deutschen
mannschaft einzig das knie von thomas
müller drückt die stimmungslage mal sehr
hängen jetzt wollen wir mal abwarten bis
morgen thomas müller war heute beim
abschlusstraining nicht dabei vielleicht
vielleicht sieht es morgen früh noch ein
bisschen besser aus und dann müssen wir
erst morgen mittag dann irgendwie eine
endgültige entscheidung treffen
als möglicher müller ersatz kommen wohl
am ehesten lina saneh und leon goretzka
anfrage aber egal wer spielt wichtiger
als die aufstellung ist die einstellung
ungarn darf auf keinen fall unterschätzt
werden
das darf uns nicht passieren das ist
ganz wichtig dass weder cool bleiben
dass wir wissen dass wir erst ein spiel
gewonnen haben gewinnt das dfb team nach
dem spiel gegen portugal nun auch morgen
gegen ungarn ist unter umständen sogar
der gruppensieg möglich bei einer
niederlage aber könnte die
europameisterschafts reise bereits nach
der vorrunde vorbei sein
deutschland gegen ungarn morgen live zu
sehen bei uns der fußballabend im zdf
der wind aber schon um 17 05 mit dem
spiel slowakei gegen spanien ja gestern
die magische nacht von kopenhagen
dänemark gruppen letzter mit null
punkten spielt sich in einen wahren
rausch gepusht vom heimischen publikum
bewegt russland mit 4 zu 1 wird
gruppenzweiter und zieht ins
achtelfinale ein
auch beim public viewing in kopenhagen
feiern die dänen das weiterkommen ihrer
mannschaft bis in die nacht
ich war noch nie so glücklich über einen
zweiten platz das frühe 1 0 von daums
court die initialzündung und denner
steine mit der name der
nationalmannschaft ist programm
die wucht mit der christen sind in der
79 minute das 3 1 erzielt lässt das
parken stadion förmlich explodieren
einfach geil als fußballer passiert es
sich so oft es speziell nicht als
dänemark zu hause ist so ein sieg zu
feiern so ein großes turnier
dann warten auf den abpfiff im
parallelspiel durch finnlands niederlage
kommt dänemark ins achtelfinale
gegner dort wales der hoffentlich hat
das deutsche team morgen abend auch
allen grund zu feiern
ja weil im norden freundlich im süden
gewittrig das ist das wetter in kurzform
er hat gleich katja roll over das heute
journal um viertel vor zehn mit bettina
schausten
wir danken für heute und freuen uns auf
morgen machen sie sich einen schönen
abend
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren kaum ist
das eine tief nach polen abgezogen kommt
schon das nächste gleich hinterher
aber diese kühlere luft aus nordwesten
die flutet jetzt immer mehr mitteleuropa
und damit wird die schwüle hitze nach
osten abgedrängt so liegen morgen die
höchsttemperaturen im süden finnlands
bei 30 grad und nördlich von moskau sind
das sogar 35 grad damit ist es dort
genauso waren die am östlichen
mittelmeer oder in nordafrika bei uns
liegen die nacht temperaturen zwischen
16 und 8 karten besonders in
süddeutschland müssen sie sich auf
kräftige schauer und gewitter einstellen
zum teil mit richtig viel regen diese
gewitter ziehen dann morgen laufe des
vormittags aus deutschland raus dann
wird erst mal freundlich einzelne kleine
schauer an der nordsee sind nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen aber von südwesten
da beginnt es schon wieder zu brodeln
diese neuen schauer und gewitter die
weiten sich dann am nachmittag über die
gesamte südhälfte aus und wahrscheinlich
so gegen 21.22 uhr können die gewitter
auch münchen erreichen
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 17 grad auf den ostfriesischen
inseln und 27 grad an der donau und
langsam beruhigt sich das wetter bis zum
wochenende stellen abend noch